Michelle Obama says be angry be angry be
angry okay
and this clouds people's thinking the
best example of this I saw was a OC
yesterday a OC complaining about how
people weren't giving her enough
adulation a SC tweets a quote the press
secretary Kaley mcenany wouldn't be the
first person to mistake a woman of color
for having a lower position or title
than she does
but Kaley in case you haven't picked up
a newspaper in two years I'm a
congresswoman so now I saw this tweet I
thought wait did Caitlin mcenany not
refer to AOC by her title I mean you
know come on insisting on someone using
their your own title is a silly thing
and it's a prideful thing to do anyway
especially if your congresswoman but
maybe she didn't do it because AOC went
on she goes the press secretary cumin is
steeped in a long hurtful and horrendous
history of stripping women of color of
titles and diminishing them to the help
perhaps she isn't aware that what she
did is mired in racist history if that
is the case I look forward to her
apology tomorrow I said gosh this press
secretary Kaley mcenany she is a
disrespectful and a racist and Alma and
what did she do the allegation is that
that the press secretary did not refer
to AOC as a congresswoman so is that
what really happened
here's Kaley mackaninee the president is
appalled by the defund the police
movement the fact that you have sitting
Congress women wanting to defund the
police notably Rasheeda to leave notably
Biden advisor AOC Alexandria Ocasio
Cortes a former Clinton and Eric Holder
spokesperson Brian Fallon wanting to
defund our police across this country it
is extraordinary hold on pause there she
referred to AOC as a congresswoman she
said you've got prominent congresswoman
notably she names some of the squad
notably AOC she notes that in addition
to being a congressman woman AOC is a
Biden adviser because frankly it's more
impressive to be a Biden adviser than it
is to be a member of Congress right
there are fewer Biden advisors
then there are members of Congress but
she actually gave her the title and AOC
had to invent this reason to be
disrespected the thing that's most
frustrating about the AOC comment isn't
even the you know constantly playing the
victim which AOC has to do the left
always has to do it's the just a
pridefulness of it do you remember there
was that guy
Lieutenant Colonel Vin de Minh he was is
a liberal guy and he was testifying and
some some congressmen referred to him as
mr. VIN Minh they all refer to each
other as mr. and mrs. Wright and Binh
Minh said excuse me ma you might need to
refer to me as lieutenant-colonel VIN
Minh could give me a break do take a
freaking chill pill I haven't tried yet
I promise you try just one little drop
of humility it will make your life
better if you live your life as someone
who's very prideful and you insist on
all the accolades and you insist on
getting every single thing you deserve
and constantly being being praised and
lauded you will not live a very happy
life if you're just thinking about every
slight that ever occurs to you or non
slight in the case of AOC imaginary
slight you won't be very happy but if
you try a little just a little touch of
humility you will feel much better
[Music]
[Music]